we're printing $100,000 every 3 seconds
of debt $100,000 every 3 seconds it's
probably be a million dollars every 30
seconds2 million a minute probably going
to be a quintilian dollars in our
lifetime I love how Thomas Massie wears
the pin the yeah it actively calculates
the gave one to Ron Paul it made me very
happy I love that guy Thomas M yeah
people people don't understand what this
means because they're like what does
that mean I don't I don't know anything
about that like I have my money it means
that right now you want to buy a house
you're not going to be able to it means
that your milk that you buy today is
going to cost twice as much tomorrow
that's if nothing changes if we're on
this stay on this track forever we can
alter our our gross domestic production
capacity by pivoting to hydrogen fuel I
actually talked with James T today W
look at this current okay so the current
US uh money supply is 20.6 trillion us
treasury dollars is 1.5 trillion and the
currency and credit derivatives is 634
trillion wait no no no is that yeah
trillion
dollars damn 600 trillion uh yeah
trillion well when you hear numbers like
that it's just like what it you know
it's like what does that even mean the
only the only time that anyone has ever
used those numbers outside of the
national debt is in like physics when
you're talking about the numbers of like
particles in the Universe you know it's
like it it takes that kind of like that
something that massive otherwise these
numbers are completely and totally
impractical the human mind can't even
comprehend it and it's the rate of
change that's also where it becomes
highly impractical holy you guys ready
for this yeah the US federal debt to GDP
ratio was
124.401
I wasn't alive we all know about the
Jimmy Carter era and John Lennon John
Lennon died in December of 1980 my
mother what you say it was in 1980 the
the uh 34.7 oh okay and that this is
this is I believe 80 was Carter right
yeah well or was that that when he was
he was getting out yeah Reagan was
elected in in 80 right or 79 and then
was put in office in the 80 in 80 or
something like that or it's 80 81 I
think maybe yeah and you know I can't
verify that this website's actually
legit either I never have been able to
verify the Deb this all public data yeah
yeah and then I remember it was deal
because one day it put like Jesus Christ
as Lord on the on the front page and you
to like exit out to see and people
people were like wow like conservatives
were all like whoa holy crap because
this is like a big website MH something
like that happened it was recently I
think look at this the interest on the
debt
$676
billion that's not even that much is
that a lot of money I thought it was
going to be more than that the interest
on the debt is going
up that's I've always considered no I
think this is specifically for um the
interest on the debt is for Medicare
Social Security and
defense wow but the issue is that's
that's not the debt that's the interest
on top it's going up we we're not paying
that down as Ian often brings us up if
the interest keeps going up you can't
pay back more interest by taking another
loan to pay back you get more interest
yep we need to increase the value of our
dollar is what we need to do worldwide
gold standard yeah or I I'm big into
hydrogen fuel and because if we can
start producing things that are val or
and graphine because if we can start
producing things that we can sell around
the world graphine like $60,000 a ton
and they are just churning it out at
Rice University right now you know
what's what is that stuff that like blue
crab blood or whatever you know what I'm
talking about blue crude no is that what
they call it horseshoe crab blood like
the most expensive material in the world
or something I'm from I'm from Long
Island and we just had the every once in
a while some random like horseshoe crab
genocide would happen or something and
they just be all over the beach and I
always hear that it's worth they it's
like worth money they blood and I'm like
man I should have been collecting their
blood when I was a kid those are like
the blue blue horseshoe cribs or
whatever and they like hook them all up
to tubes and extract blood slowly and
it's like I don't know what the deal is
but i' I've seen that antibacterial it's
valued in the medical industry but we
need like when you talk about a dollar
like I'm a Libertarian so you always
we're always talking about the gold
standard but you know we could have a
different commodity based dollar there
are different things that can back the
dollar hey we can go to 2027 we can go
to the Future based on all these
projections where will be oh give it to
me oh my God I love this this is four
years from now four years from now the
average family is going to have $100,000
in their savings that is really bad that
is not good it says today that the
average family has 11,000 yep and it
says it's going to be 10x in four years
and if the uh the debt to GDP ratio goes
from 124 124% to 150% that means the
buying the just a general correlation is
not perfect but that 10x increase and
how much money you have correlates with
like a 12 12 times decrease in your
buying power spend your dollars get rid
of them buy e like I know that like
there's there's people that that sounds
like Financial advice Phil oh yeah well
I'm not giving you any Financial advice
kind I like to spend dollars and get
things that are valuable I I know that
that you know whether it be Bitcoin or
gold or silver or ammo or whatever land
is great you know buy I think that you
know I'm going to be buying things that
are going to retain value or go up in
value I'm probably not going to be
hanging on to very much cash in machines
that I can use to increase my income my
profitability things like that a really
good camera really good microphone if
you use it I mean look I'm not assets
per citizen per citizen 1.2 million I
ain't telling you what to do but
Electronics don't hold their value yeah
but it's you use it in the shortterm to
increase productivity essentially I've
turned into like a civil war nerd since
I moved to Virginia because I there's
like a million battlefields where I live
and there's signs everywhere you notice
like you you you'll go to a dock for
like to launch a fishing boat and
there's like a sign be like this is
where this General General I lived near
Petersburg and it was like almost a
years long Siege around the city so
there's battles everywhere but it's got
me kind of collecting like old antiques
and that's actually a really good
investment is like really old antiques
they just uh like a like a Charizard go
up in value I was think I used to have
so many the crazy thing is I think I had
probably like five first edition
Charizards when I was a kid and they
were like worth a little bit I don't
even know what happened to them they're
all gone but now they're worth like 10
to $20,000 you checked your babies ever
get I have not I lost all magic cards
that was brutal one day on a train I I
was we're on a train and I was like I
fell asleep and then they're like oh
we're at our stop get up and I get up
and jump off the train and I go I turn
back and the door closes and I'm like
all my card's gone and that was that's
probably 100 Grand worth of magic cards
going yeah they really worth that much
now yeah but but because the cards back
then were not that not that valuable but
we're talking
25 24 years
now they're all extremely rare and out
of print and more valuable I wonder what
Alpha Black Lotus is what
1.2 million for an alpha Black Lotus was
is it like rated 10 yeah. yeah the most
valuable Magic
card 1.2 million that thing was like
60600 you're probably looking like a
special auction because a rated eight is
140 Grand okay that's
crazy wow $1 million for a freaking
piece of it was 700 when I was a kid and
we were like wow $700 that's
crazy man wow who knows what's going to
be worth money you know what I'm saying
that's the thing do you remember the
Beanie Babies everybody was like oh
these are going to be worth something
one day but I don't think they ever were
nope that was that was a tulip thing
that was a Dutch tulip Fiasco but Phil I
think a cool thing for you to like spend
money on and collect you could get
antique like firearms from like the
1800s yeah and they look awesome and you
can mount them on your wall and they
just grow in value
oh wow that's an actual Union Civil War
rifled musket yeah that's awesome I have
a breach loader uh I forget the name of
it that's what I need breach loader
breach loading rifle from the Civil
Warrior I have a pinfire revolver uh
which is kind of a rare type um pin fire
like it had a little pin that stuck out
of it and the hammer would hit the pin
and that's what would fire the shell oh
wow yeah they didn't really they weren't
around for long but uh Calvary officers
had them on the Union and Confederate
side so it's pretty cool it's like I got
I bought it for like 800 bucks a few
years ago and it's just they used you
know the longer you hold on to it the
more valuable I think the revolvers back
then were uh the more ubiquitous was the
percussion cap and that's so like little
metal primer goes in the back of you
know each chamber and then it hits the
primer which ignites the the musket ball
or whatever whatever they were using the
bullet at the time we we've actually got
some actual Civil War bullets because uh
we have a civil war bayonet somewhere oh
yeah yeah we found it on the property
yeah and it's all rusted and you know
and we're just like oh whatever they're
they they're all over the place it's
super cool I've been metal detected on
my property cuz there's a battle my I'm
I'm wondering what relics people will
find from the next civil war so they're
going to find you know mag iPhone iPhone
15 and uh my uh my buddy back in in New
Hampshire he he does a lot of metal
detecting and he's trying to get into uh
off liit places because you know New
England's been around a long time so
people have done a lot of hunting and
stuff so he's trying to find places
where he's not allowed that he can sneak
into I won't blow him up I'm kind of
like yeah if we sit around and and just
kind of complain for the next 6 months
it could be the end of the world but if
we really Pioneer new tech like hydrogen
Tech and really push it really push it
we could probably come out of this on
top it depends so if what we're facing
right now is actually a legitimate
threat of World War II the population
decrease from war and from the fact that
people don't have kids means what you're
hoping for is less likely to occur Tech
technological expansion typically
requires population
expansion like the the how many people
does it take to make one monitor screen
it's it probably like 500 different
Specialties to make one computer monitor
but because of the international economy
and how everything operates someone gets
Cobalt here and someone gets you know
quartz here and someone mines the the
oil or DRS for the oil over here and
then they all go on these different
marketplaces I think a really good
example is probably just like pod Thai
or something some like ridiculous dish
that has a spice from Asia and a a
vegetable from Mexico and you're like
this this unnatural demonic food would
never exist were it not for our big oil
tankers you know our big cargo ships
around the oceans to bring all these
ingredients together true if the
population declines too much you lose
Specialties and then you're going to
have a guy's going to be like look man
we need someone who can extract hydrogen
but we don't have that anymore so I can
work on that but then we don't have a
guy who handles the Plastics we don't
have a guy who handles the the the
electronics Ian you're worried about
like the world World War III bringing
the world to an end or is there
something else you worried about is it
World War that's got you nervous yeah
yeah CU you know for what I do I
basically read the new you know all day
every day I sort through like hundreds
of news articles read about this uh you
know war in Ukraine tensions with China
and all that and I don't like to be
hyperbolic in my show and stuff but I
always say like if we wake up tomorrow
and Russia bombed a NATO base in Poland
and we're actually at war with Russia or
if a chinese ship and a American ship
shot at each other in the South China
Sea and then a bunch of it escalated and
all of a sudden we're at war with China
you know don't be surprised we shouldn't
be surprised because this the state of
the world that we're in right now what
they're just pushing everybody all over
the planet it's really uh you know it is
very scary and again I don't try to be
over hyperbolic but what they're doing
they're leading us down a path of global
war the likes of which you know we've
never seen especially with new
technology and I I I always I always
want to stress too cuz especially when
we had uh you know I'll shout out again
culture War podcast youtube.com timcast
uh Stephen Marsh and I were talking
before the show started because he was I
show him the Civil War rifle and he was
like what was the first the first battle
and I was like uh Bull Run manessis and
he was like right right and they didn't
even think it wasn't even a battle it
was like a street fight like nobody knew
it was going on and I'm like yes what we
consider to be the first battle I mean
obviously Fort Sumter is a start of but
that wasn't even a battle it was like uh
only one guy died and it was an accident
I don't think anybody died one guy it
was an accident it was one death it was
accidental it was like uh I can't
remember exactly what happened but uh
then you had the B the First Battle of
Bull Run and no one thought the fight
was actually going to happen and at the
time when it did happen nobody called it
the Civil War nobody called it the war
in the states it was not a war at all
now we look back and say both sides
thought it would be over so quick so
it's
possible that in 100 years they say
World War III started uh December of
2022 yeah it's possible they say it
started with the with the Russian
invasion of Ukraine the US respond think
of it as 9911
personally the US was just stomping on
everyone's neck for the first 18 years
of it yeah but bro the US has been doing
that for a lot longer than but 9911
changed like lockdown police state crap
you know Patriot Act people were getting
you take your shoes off at the airport
kind of crap looking over your shoulder
afraid of Muslims like all this dumb
I'll tell you so just an an anecdote
when I went to China I remember getting
in or I was getting on the plane to fly
I forget where we were flying next but I
was all nervous going through their
security I was like I'm going to have to
take my shoes off it's China they're
going to really go crazy and Pat me down
and I started like taking my belt off
and they were just like come on come on
through and they just like hit me with
the wand and I was like oh wow and then
when we got back into the US my wife
bought like some hand cream in Australia
and they put it in like a special bag
and they were like you can't you know
they like shook her down and like ripped
apart all her stuff and said she
couldn't bring it in or if she wanted to
she had to like mail it to it was crazy
I'm like this is just the the remnants
of of 911 of what they did to us after
that it hasn't gone away I mean I don't
know if it's the remnants of 911 there
the thing that we're experiencing is not
actually about stopping terrorism yeah
it's the it's the fact that once you
start a government program they never go
away it's the infrastructure for the TSA
that was designed for you know designed
initially to stop terrorism never
stopped a thing it's an addiction yeah
so what happens is the US government
says we're going to spend $100 million
on war they invest in all these
companies the companies build up a big
employee base they hire a bunch of
people next year comes around and that
company goes to Congress and says are
you are you going to give us that same
deal again go well I don't think we need
it there's no war and they go listen we
employ 500 people in your district and
if we don't have this contract we're
firing them and we're going to tell them
it's because of you no no no no no no no
no no you you got my vote you got my
vote yeah yep so what we got to do is
make hit
music I'm talking like Marvin Gay I've
been really we need to make babies and
we need to inspire people to have sex
and have children and that's music
that's like because if we have kids it's
not enough you need to you need to mass
produce love and we need to make
hydrogen fuel and graphine to get out of
this steel hell hole that we're in and
start making lightweight super conductor
conductors locally really fast and
cheaply I I you
know I got to stop right here Ian is
completely correct on
graphine because steel was such a large
component of our industry of our jobs of
our economy uh the Steelers Pittsburgh
how much steel is still being made in
the US I do not believe very much but uh
either way if we had an industrial
revolution on par with uh you know what
it was in the past and we bring back a
bunch of jobs you could have
manufacturing plants pop up all over the
place it could Revitalize uh dying towns
it could create new cities and it's it's
going to have to be you know we we we we
we often do joke about graphine and
Ian's fervor but the reality
is it is a bold move to reconfigure an
economy towards building a material that
can be used to expand and create a bunch
of new products uh my favorite example A
lot of the stuff we use plastics for
instance and I think paper towels a
bunch of stuff were invented uh for
space so like a lot of the things we use
are invented by yeah the space race and
then it's like oh this is convenient
people might want to use it thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net